thank you very much I'm so happy to be
here how have you enjoyed past two days
that wasn't that much have you liked it
that's the spirit and so maybe first of
all we've had great talks and you're all
great people so maybe give a big hand to
the organizers give it up for them
so last talked let's do this before I
start I want to give a trigger warning
for this talk this hope will include
mention of harassment misogyny
transphobia homophobia racism sexism
rape and death threats and abuse so as
Jake so eloquently said my name is Lena
vinod I'm a team leader consultant
writer and photographer and Carly live
in Berlin in Germany and if you're on
Twitter my user handle there is a tell
our and RD sarto remember remember so I
put it on the slides and today I want to
talk to you about software bugs because
that's such a great topic raise your
hands who of you is a software developer
that's quite plenty maybe sixty percent
two of you like software with bugs maybe
10 people I want to have a conversation
with you later and two of you enjoys
that moment when you fix the bug and
software works again that's almost
everyone awesome so bug fixing what are
bugs software bugs are errors flaws or
failures in software that cause the
software to produce incorrect undesired
or unexpected output a but can be many
things like a system error performance
problem configuration issue or an issue
with functionality at all points in the
development cycle we can end up with
thoughts and our software so we need to
debug it we need to find and resolve
these defects that we have in a system
or in a software but debugging can be
hard and it becomes even harder the more
complex or software becomes in debugging
one of the most interesting and
difficult challenges is spaghetti code
spaghetti code is slang for code that's
unnecessarily complex convoluted and
difficult to read or follow by human
just like it's very difficult to follow
one single piece of spaghetti when you
have a pastor mountain on your plate
spaghetti code can be code that's not
organized uses lots of go-to statements
has many interdependencies or jumps
around between different areas or files
it has often grown over many years and
many people have contributed to it and
it's very difficult to debug as people
in tech were used to bugs they kept
their part of our daily lives but
there's another thing that's part of our
lives a software developers and other
people in tech another system that
contains bugs the tech industry itself
in this talk I will show you in which
ways this industry is buggy why we
should care about that and how to debug
it the tech industry is a lot like a big
system of spaghetti code it has grown
over time and many people have
contributed to it it's also a system
that contains many different intertwined
parts with dependencies and it it's
important it's an important system with
huge impact it's still one of the
fastest growing industries worldwide and
technology or lack thereof influences
the daily lives of many people worldwide
this is why we need to look at this
industry and its effects to understand
the system it helps understand it its
parts so let's look at which parts
define the tech industry as a system
I've created a simplified Venn diagram
to show them to you first of all you can
see society much like software systems
don't exist in isolation the tech
industry also belongs to something
larger part of the tech industry are
communities like floss or free libre and
open source software communities or
local tech communities then we have
companies some companies or the people
in them contribute to communities or a
part of them so we have an overlap here
and finally there are humans and here
you can see one of us this is me and
this is you some of us work at companies
some of us are part of communities all
of us are in some way in tech
and all these parts together influence
this industry one of the most common
problems in handling bugs as you may all
know is the misconception of what
actually constitutes a bug the classic
question is it a bug or is it a feature
when debugging software systems we bring
our very own personal and technical
skills preferences knowledge 'as and
limitations so when you want to
understand how these different parts
we've looked at our influence the tech
industry we need to understand ourselves
first our own skills abilities and
limitations some effects can exist in
our society with ease and can influence
which gives us advantages relative to
other people we have privileged
privileged comes from various factors
like our gender race class education
upbringing our ability appearance
physical and mental health and many more
privilege is a shield that protects us
from problems and it blocks parts of our
perception privilege is like being in
your cozy sunny home over there reading
a book and not even noticing that a
thunderstorm is about to happen around
you the thunderstorm that could cause
the people outside their lives
privileged in tech is when you can
attend a conference party without fear
that someone will harass you when you
can have drinks with colleagues every
other night because you don't have to
take care of the child or elderly
relatives at home privileged in tech is
when you can stand in the daily stand-up
meeting and don't have to sit because of
a disability or illness and when you can
publish a post about a framework online
without getting rape or death threats in
return privilege is a classic example of
but it works on my machine or but it
works in my life it puts us in a
position where we don't see problems in
tech because we're not personally
affected by them a position where we
don't even have to think about the fact
that not all lives and all
jeans are the same privilege is a
comfortable position of ignorance and we
have to actively work through our
privileges to make sure we see more than
our tiny portion of the world and to
understand what the tech industry really
looks like another factor that limits
our perception our biases every moment
our brains receive 11 million pieces of
information but we can only process 40
of those pieces pieces with our
conscious biases our assumptions we use
to deal with this huge amount of
information that our brains receive and
biases are attached to the idea that we
can judge something just by looking at
it they're based on our past knowledge
experiences and cultural norms biases
are great for seeing there's an animal
it has four legs lots of hair it's light
brown and it's not a dog or cat this is
a lion I should run but biases are not
good for judging people that we use them
for it and we even think that we're
being objective while doing so these
biases lead to unfair preferences women
earn less money for the exact same job
than men do candidates who are
interviewed on sunny days have a better
chance of being hired then candidus
candidates were interviewed on rainy
days and tall men move into leadership
positions more frequently than shorter
mean we all have these biases
understanding in which ways we're biased
can help us understand the text adders
of tech better and who are personally
contributing to it an extremely
important skill all of us need is
empathy and many people have mentioned
it over the past two days empathy is the
ability to relate to another person as
though they were us it's a powerful
skill that enables us to think of the
consequences of our words and actions on
people and as humans working on software
empathy is our responsibility
and we also needed to understand the
status of the tech industry as we've
seen up to now understanding our
privileges working through our biases
and practicing empathy helps us
understand the status of our system now
let's use this knowledge to run a
systems diagnosis of the tech industry
and its parts the smallest entity in the
system is one human and we've talked
about ourselves already but our
privileges biases and lack of empathy
next up we have companies Conway's law
says that systems which are designed in
organizations are copies of the
communication structures in these
organizations this means that our
company structures will directly
influence the software we build whether
we are aware of it or not so what do the
structures in our organizations look
like most European tech companies
consist mostly of sis white mini and sis
means that a person's experience of
their own gender matches the sex they
were assigned at Birth in Europe less
than thirty percent of employees in tech
are women in less than ten percent
worker software developers so more than
ninety percent of software developers in
Europe arsis white min and we don't even
have data on other aspects of humanity
we don't even have numbers on how many
people of color lesbian gay bisexual
queer non-binary intersexual people or
disabled people work in tech here and
these are just examples of many groups
that are currently hugely
underrepresented in this industry what
we have are homogeneous organizations we
have a huge lack of diversity in
ethnicities genders backgrounds
education upbringing life experiences
ages languages ideas disabilities and
abilities and more but creativity is an
important driver for good design
nearing but our ability to be truly
creative in our teams depends on exactly
these factors this is one of the reasons
why our lack of diversity is so harmful
it even blocks our ability to be truly
creative when we design and build
software we all live in diverse
societies but our organizations don't
reflect that the products we build in
these homogenous organizations right now
just don't work for our diverse
population which even makes many of our
products completely unusable for so many
people thing is even if tech companies
manage to hire a diverse workforce most
of the times they don't keep them
forty-one percent of women leave careers
in technology after ten years that's
more than twice the number of min the
reason for these bad retention rates is
that our companies fail at inclusion
inclusion means that all individuals in
a group are being valued respected and
supported and it means facilitating
cultures practices and relationships to
support a diverse workforce so right now
it's hard getting members of
underrepresented groups into tech
because it's such a hostile environment
and as soon as they are in we largely
drive these skilled experts out again in
a very short time because we don't
really care about them this goes for our
companies and also goes for our
communities the lack of diversity and
inclusion in our communities is even
worse than an average companies 85 to 95
percent of all contributors to free
labor and open source software projects
are min they're also mostly white and
most of them are software developers
very few people with other professions
and expertise contribute to these
projects and since these contributions
are mostly expected to be done in
people's airtime everyone who has other
obligations by caring for children is
excluded and most projects are neither
accessible no
coming for beginners another big issue
in communities is harassment there are
hundreds of reports of harassment
misogyny transphobia homophobia racism
threats sexism and abuse that people
have experienced in floss projects in
the communities and at events our tech
communities are completely unsafe space
for underrepresented groups in tech
right now and on top of all of that our
society's influence as personally and
the tech industry we live in patriarchy
a social construct that is oppressive on
humans our societies are also capitalist
systems that have led to wealth and
income inequalities and we live in
racist societies that Center upon the
false belief that white people are
superior to add people of other racial
backgrounds together patriarchy
capitalism and racism have led to
oppressive systems these systems are big
influencers on ourselves our beliefs and
our work in tech we've now looked at all
these parts isolated from each other but
a system is more than just the sum of
its parts but I mean your developers you
know that all parts that influence the
tech industry are intertwined and
accumulate characteristics of other
poets which has made many of them even
worse as a system the tech industry is a
place full of privilege biases that legs
empathy diversity and inclusion is full
of harassment and is shaped by
patriarchy capitalism and racism so how
do we handle this
when we want to understand and debug an
unfamiliar system it helps to play
around with variables and see how they
affect the output one of the outputs of
the tech industry as a system is the
software we build so let's see what the
software looks like software can have
positive impact on people's lives
software can help satisfy our basic
human needs for safety belonging and
self-actualization for example by
helping us communicate with others for
applications or by making information
and communication tools accessible for
people through screen readers software
like the application be my eyes also
helps people with visual impairments
catalpa certain tasks and some software
can also help people with mental or
physical illnesses improve their
situation through online self-help
programs but software also causes lots
of harm and it can even endanger
people's lives our software is sexist
when virtual assistants like Apple's
Siri Google now or Microsoft Cortana are
told that a user had a heart attack they
redirect them to help but none of these
assistance has been programmed to
recognize what it means when a user
sense that they're being abused which
affects one in three women worldwide our
software is racist face recognition
algorithms in camera sensors keep on
failing to recognize the faces of people
of color correctly our software worsens
issues in societies vacation rental and
accommodation sharing sites like Airbnb
are contributing to a growing housing
crisis in cities like New York London
and Berlin by removing rental stock from
already tight housing markets our
software also exposes people to
harassment and abuse major tech
companies like Twitter and Facebook have
been failing to address the harassment
issues on their platforms for years
which has made many of these important
technologies completely unusable for
many people
our software also puts people at risk on
a regular basis we expose users too
dangerous through security flaws and
we've built tools that have enabled
personal data to be exposed online which
has put people's personal safety at
stake and car dispatch startups like
uber keep not doing anything to ensure
passenger safety in the cars despite
several cases of assault against
passengers over the past years and our
software is actively making people sick
the animations in our operating systems
apps and websites can trigger panic
attacks to people and software has
helped cars emit more pollution on the
road than in regulatory tests pollution
that is making people sick this is the
output of the tech industry as a system
we are part of the system and this is
what all worked us to people and even if
the technology you're working on right
now may feel like a good project for you
and you feel like it doesn't do any harm
you need to care about that as well what
we need to understand is that as people
in tech we have a collective
responsibility we keep pretending that
the technology we build is neutral we
still believe that we can be a political
as people in check we keep pretending
that our algorithms on you troll and we
don't care about the ethical aspects of
our work and most of us are in a
position where we don't have to care but
it's our responsibility to understand
technology is not neutral or code is not
neutral our work is political and our
work has consequences on actual lives
what we have right now is a completely
broken system right now this industry is
system built on privilege by privileged
people for privileged people this system
works for sis white men inside and
outside of this industry but for almost
no one else right now we're failing many
underrepresented people inside of tech
and the system come generate meaningful
put we're failing to build real
solutions for our software User's actual
problems this is why we need to change
this industry's inner mechanisms and its
output to something meaningful we need
to debug it but who is we as we've seen
one reason for this industry's problem
exists between keyboard and chair and
this time it's not our users this time
it's us as humans we are contributing to
the status of this tech industry but
we're also part of the solution for
these problems here's wine if you look
closely at this Venn diagram again
you'll see that there's one spot where
all pods overlap this one's bought with
one person who is in tech as part of a
team or community or by themselves this
person is you this place right where you
are this is where debugging the tech
industry happens every one of us has
this area where we can fix things every
one of us is part of something bigger
we're working at companies some of us
are part of communities we know other
people in this industry whatever you do
in tech you have such an area the sizes
of our areas defer the more privilege
and power we have the bigger our area is
in which we can make this change happen
and the more it is our responsibility to
do just that but what we experience
right now as an industry is another case
of it works on my machine so your
problem isn't real right now many areas
for change go unused because many of us
don't know or don't care about the
brokenness of the system because the
system works for us and we benefit from
the status quo right now most of the
people who are already working on
debugging this industry are members of
underrepresented groups in tech that's a
bit like telling the QA team in your
company
that they have to fix the bugs they find
themselves because you have better
things to do but it's the responsibility
of all of us to help debug this industry
it's my responsibility and it's your
responsibility change thoughts in this
area change starts with me and change
thoughts with you
over the next minutes I'll show you 11
debugging tools and techniques that you
can use to support the debugging process
in the tech industry debugging starts
with ourselves and the basis for all
debugging work step 1 learning we need
to educate ourselves and learn about
systemic issues and depression in tech
there are many great resources online
that can help you understand to this
debugging process it's not the
responsibility of others to educate us
learning about debugging the tech
industry is our personal responsibility
we need to practice empathy empathy and
actually caring about other people is a
choice and a skill we can improve we
need to understand that not everyone is
like us and understand that the life
experiences of people who are different
from us are just as valid as our own
empathy also means understanding that
our software is a personal experience
for our users all expressions and
interactions we build in our software
are choices that affect the way our
users feel we can't be good designers
and software developers if we don't
actively work on our empathy step three
is to understand our position in the
world as people in tech we have power
the tech industry has turned this notion
of power into a culture of celebrating
so called coder ninjas rock stars and
unicorns I hate to break the news to you
but we're not none of us are ninjas rock
stars unicorns all of us are humans and
all of us fail this should fill us with
humbleness and awareness of our own
limitations and should have us work on
all humility step four is understanding
our privileges we need to understand how
our position in the world has been
shaped in terms of privilege and class
and race and in which ways we benefit
from the existing systems around us this
can be a chance for us to learn which
mistakes we've made in the
costs and how we can prevent these
mistakes in the future we also need to
use a privilege for good work on
ourselves and set positive examples for
our peers we need to work through our
biases we need to be conscious about our
past present and huge yourself and be
deliberate about our actions and
interactions with people practically
this also means being deliberate about
the software we build and making sure
that the software is not only appealing
to people who are like us every app icon
matters and every image matters
companies and communities need to put
policies in place to work through biases
and avoid basing our work on assumptions
about the people we work with and the
people who use our software we need to
listen to what underrepresented people
in tech have to say follow them on
Twitter read their blogs and
publications and look outside of your
existing networks we need to actively
look for the voices we haven't heard
before and we need to amplify these
voices the voices of people whose
stories often remain unheard to help
them reach border audiences amplifying
others voices also means speaking less
there is no need to comment on
everything that underrepresented people
in tech are sharing we need to listen we
also need to work on diversity first and
foremost diversity is our moral
obligation it's the only way to do
software development right the only way
to do right by the people in tech and by
our software uses diversity also enables
us to build products that are actually
useful for people it also allows us to
solve complex complex problems better
and faster be more creative make better
decisions and generate more innovation
companies with diverse leadership have
better sales revenue
customers higher market share and higher
profits than their competitors diversity
also helps companies with hiring
learning leads to better software and
happier customers and still diversity is
our moral obligation it's the only way
to do software right there is no
alternative and there's no alternative
to inclusion either we need to work on
inclusion in our workplaces and
communities we need to foster
environments in which diverse groups of
people can thrive it's our
responsibility as privileged people in
tech to facilitate spaces in which under
represented people want to be we also
need policies for equality and social
conduct and we need to communicate
openly about our values we need to do
everything to make spaces welcoming and
safe for everyone and our efforts that
going to inclusion show how much we
actually care about diversity we also
need to give give our knowledge
technical skills time and money to
groups or individuals in this industry
who I need of support we can become
coaches at meetups or become mentors we
can donate money to organizations like
trans heck women who code rails girls
black girls code or Model View culture
that do important work to debug this
industry and each of us needs to work on
being an ally to underrepresented groups
in tech being an ally means supporting
these people by following the tender for
mentioned steps educating ourselves
practicing empathy working on our
humility working through our privileges
and biases listening amplifying their
voices working on diversity and
inclusion and by giving and by
continuing to learn and work on
ourselves being an ally is ongoing work
but as allies we can support the people
who are
fighting to debug this industry this is
what we need to do and we need to do it
now the Cody riding today will soon be
obsolete the software we're building
today will already be outdated in a few
weeks the bugs we're producing today
will be fixed and the features we build
will change again what we have now is a
chance to build something bigger
something that lasts what we have now is
the chance to debug the tech industry
and make it a better system that is
about justice and equality this
debugging is already happening and it
can't be stopped it is the biggest
challenge and the biggest task we have
as people in tech right now now is the
time for us to debug this industry and
make technology a place for everyone
this is our chance to build our own
legacy this change that's with all of us
it starts with me it starts with you
problem exists between keyboard and
chair solution exists between keyboard
and chair and the question is now that
we are debugging the tech industry will
you join us thank
you